[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi dans une bibliothèque je suis assez
d'accord avec ce que dit et avec valérie
alors fardeau de la télé oui c'est vrai
17h07 c'est parti là jusqu'en décembre
là bas ma madrague heure d'hiver rats
sera pas de soleil je veux de la dark à
jeudi avait été très énervé a été
interviewé par lepoint geneviève a
immédiatement réagi à la déclaration
[Rires]
non ça faut savoir que le métier de
chanteur ou qui vous a donné la part je
sais pas j'ai vu votre doit arriver non
je sais quoi doit arriver
allez on va faire un disque d'or sujet
avec fabien lecoeuvre
[Applaudissements]
sophie davant avait conclu et c'est ça
par contre je vous dire pour l'emploi
south pole des émissions où beaucoup de
gens disent on veut voir la séquence du
détecteur de mon fiancé détecte le
mensonge
grâce à la voix en disant il ya eu déjà
des dizaines de chroniqueuse est-ce que
vous en avez déjà secrètement qui fait
c'était la prochaine question
[Applaudissements]
voilà il est temps de vous adresser à
des canaux à quoi à recharger des
batteries
c'est bien c'est bon allez vers signé
vocation mais je crois qu'elles sont
chargées de montreuil n'a pas montré son
fruité
voilà ce que vous savez une vérité à me
dire tu as bernard
[Applaudissements]
vous avez eu un rapport sexuel il ya
moins de 24 heures après ce que nous
venons résine l'a dit moi le personnage
[Musique]
d'originalité
[Applaudissements]
ça fait
[Musique]
l'essai
c'est vrai qu'on y est
fabien lecoeuvre savamment fabien très
bien parce que j'ai changé mes oreilles
et c'est plus les bons dans un lit bébé
[Rires]
grandit à windsor pas dans un lit toi tu
dors dans une cabine à uv
[Applaudissements]
à côté elle dort dans un cercueil et
parce que c'est la couleur qui vous gêne
non c'est la note
[Musique]